after irrepressible pain
and protests a pause
not death dominating but life
george floyd's the man who has sparked a
racial
reckoning for america george he was like
a general
every day he walks outside it'd be a
line of people
like just like when we came in wanting
to greet him and
wanted to have fun with him
collective mourning in a country that
spent
months separated a moment of
togetherness
to try and shake the virus that has
never left it
racism ever since 401 years ago
the reason we could never be who we
wanted and dream to be in is you kept
your knee on our neck
we were smarter than the
underfunded schools you put us in
but you had your knee on our neck
we could run corporations
and not hustle in the street but you had
your knee on our neck
we had creative skills
we could do whatever anybody else could
do
but we couldn't get your knee off our
neck
what happened to floyd happens every day
in this country
in education in health services
and in every area of american life
it's time for us to stand up in
georgia's name
and say get your knee off our necks
[Music]
deaths in police custody haunt america
but is it finally ready to atone for its
sins
in the space where he passed after
nearly nine minutes of agony
where he begged for a breath there is
hope
that change will come does this
feel different to you right now oh it
feels a lot different it feels like a
burden has been lifted off the community
it feels it feels a lot better it feels
like we've gotten some
kind of closure to a whole lot of things
that were happening
in the in the past you know because
this this this brings us back to the
1960s era
when all of these people were marching
across the country
this was better than even the 1960s 68
when dr martin luther king
this is in every state in the united
states and 168 countries in the world
this is far better than we had ever
anticipated
now all they got to do right now to fix
this get out and vote
today it feels like a corner of
contemplation
full of pensive stares
and tough conversations about the ills
of the past
and the present
it's offensive it's very offensive and
we deal with
offense offense every day you know
the whispers the jeers they're following
you around the store
young men pulled over for us to not be
able to walk around with the freedom and
the liberties
and the abilities to have the pursuit of
happiness
is just wrong it's painful because we're
mourning
for george but george represents all of
our
black boys and girls that we will not be
denied
to be change-makers agents of change so
that
on their knees washington's black
leaders
came to pay their respects
alongside them the attorney general who
brought the charges against the four
officers
we call upon the name of keith ellison
lord god
father we know that you have prepared
him every step
everything that he's done before now
lord god has prepared him for this time
lord god
may you be the strength yes of our
community
that is wheeling from the pain of losing
yet
another one this is a black issue
we're gonna keep getting justice for
some black people
there is still visceral anger
he killed me some of white america
though
now appears to be in a reflective mood
a state it has failed to reach for so
long
there are no right answers especially
coming from
white privilege i want to listen
i i know nothing yeah and we came here
to listen and
bring the kids down here to just listen
and
feel the things that they're feeling
then we're gonna go home and we're gonna
talk about it
this is a community pitching for yes
harmony
but real policy change too
ultimately it is concrete legislation
that would mark a turning point and
there is
a push for a wholesale review of the way
the police use
force what happened here caught on
camera
has made everyone confront some
uncomfortable realities
in the service they bowed their heads
for every second
george floyd suffered this time
the grief the outrage the unity
just might be enough for a new dawn
in america